hello we are looking for highly
intelligent individuals to find them we
have devised a test there is a message
hidden in this image find it and it will
lead you on the rose to finding us that
was the message from the cicada
organization that was publishing
difficult puzzles on the internet since
2011 the one who solves them gets in the
community welcome to the eye the first
few required little more than mild
coding ability and wordplay to get past
but the references became less obvious
one clue involved a poem from a
collection of medieval Welsh manuscripts
another a quote from a William Gibson
book only released on 3.5 inch floppies
cicada posters with a QR code were all
over the world however it's still
unknown who and for what purpose came up
with cicada 3301 and those who figured
it out may have already joined them to
know more watch our big video links
below
thank you